para bajar el parlamento alemán el
bundestag aprobó este jueves un nuevo
marco legal un nuevo paquete de medidas
para afrontar la cuarta ola de la
pandemia del coronavirus que está
golpeando a alemania de manera muy
dramática entre las medidas acordadas
por los parlamentarios está el regreso
al teletrabajo en la manera de lo
posible así como el acceso al transporte
público a los lugares de empleo solo
para personas que tengan el esquema
completo de vacunación que se hayan
recuperado de coronavirus o que puedan
presentar una prueba negativa este
paquete de medidas todavía debe ser
aprobado por el bundesrat la cámara alta
del parlamento alemán donde se reúnen
los 16 estados federados se espera que
se reúnan este viernes para discutir las
medidas este paquete llega en momentos
en que alemania rompe una vez más nuevos
récords de infectados a nivel nacional
con 65.000 nuevos contagios en las
últimas 24 horas y con creciente
preocupación de parte de la población
sobre lo que todo esto pueda significar
en las próximas semanas en pleno
invierno y cuando ya se acerca la
navidad